[Música]
Rusia asegura controlar una nueva ciudad
ucraniana A las afueras de doníes que en
la región del Don vas desde el gobierno
de kiev afirman que todavía hay en
marcha un Aceros batalla
el escritor salmán permanece
hospitalizado pero ya le retiraron la
respiración asistida un día después del
ataque con cuchillo del que fue víctima
en el estado de Nueva York el acusado un
joven de 24 años se declaró inocente
se cumplen 75 años de la partición entre
India y Pakistán este proceso que se
paró a estas dos naciones dejó a
millones de familias alejadas con un
trasfondo religioso Y a lo largo de tres
guerras
actualizamos las noticias en la pantalla
de France 24 Gracias por continuar con
nosotros Yo soy Juan pupilales
comenzamos en Ucrania porque dos nuevos
barcos con granos partieron desde el mar
Negro y ya son 16 los navíos que han
salido del país como parte de un acuerdo
respaldado por Naciones Unidas los de
ese sábado son dos embarcaciones con
banderas de Barbados y de Islas Marshall
que portan 12.000 toneladas de maíz y
3000 de semillas de girasol ambos
partieron rumbo a Turquía país que firmó
ese acuerdo con Ucrania y Rusia en medio
de una escasez de esos insumos a nivel
mundial sobre todo en naciones en vías
de desarrollo
Mientras tanto hay versiones encontradas
sobre la situación de pesky una pequeña
población A las afueras de la provincia
de doñesque en la región del Don vas al
este mientras en Rusia asegura que tiene
el control total de esta localidad el
gobierno ucraniano afirma que allí
siguen librándose feroces combates por
otro lado del presidente
ucranianonsky pidió a Europa que los
ciudadanos rusos no puedan cruzar la
frontera hacia el bloque comunitario
Andrés granadillo tiene el informe
cae otro objetivo en la región de doñets
eso fue lo que reportó el Ministerio de
defensa ruso que afirma haber tomado el
control de la localidad de pezki El
portavoz del Ministerio de defensa de
Rusia Igor con ashenkov dijo
las fuerzas armadas de la federación
rusa continúan una operación militar
especial en Ucrania como resultado del
avance de las fuerzas rusas y prorusas
piski en la República Popular de do
nietz ha sido completamente liberada
cerca de klamatorsk en la República
Popular de doniers un sistema de cohetes
y Mars y un depósito con municiones
fueron destruidos
precisamente cohetes rusos alcanzaron
cromators el viernes en la noche
causando la muerte a tres personas y
dejando 11 heridos Alina asegura haber
sobrevivido por estar guarecida en su
casa
es bueno si estuviéramos en la calle no
estoy segura de que pudiéramos hablar
con usted ahora todos los elementos de
los proyectiles están en el patio el
hecho de que estuviéramos dentro de la
tras los ataques que no cesan y la
guerra que ya completa casi seis meses
el presidente bolodín ir zelensky
insiste en el bloqueo a Rusia y a sus
ciudadanos
en primer lugar se debe garantizar que
los asesinos rusos y los Cómplices del
terrorismo de estado no puedan usar las
visas schenging en segundo lugar la idea
de Europa en sí misma no puede
destruirse nuestros valores europeos
comunes no pueden destruirse lo que
significa que no podemos convertir a
Europa en un supermercado donde no
importa quien venga Lo único que importa
es que se paguen las compras
entre tanto
Moscú advirtió a Washington que si
Estados Unidos convierte en ley la
propuesta de proyecto presentado en la
cámara de representantes que pide
declarar a Rusia como un estado
patrocinador del terrorismo las
relaciones bilaterales se destruirían
por completo
no abandonamos el viejo continente
porque miles de peces han aparecido
muertos en el río oder un importante
afluente de Europa central conocido en
los últimos años por ser relativamente
limpio y por albergar a unas cuarenta
especies domésticas de peces Alemania y
Polonia investigan las causas del
desastre mientras que a los expertos
pronostican que podrían necesitar años
para recuperar su estado natural arena
villacorta nos amplía
es una catástrofe ecológica miles de
peces han aparecido muertos en el río
oder que atraviesa Alemania y Polonia lo
que ha provocado advertencias de un
desastre medioambiental
veo a los animales morir ante mis ojos
sé que Los Pescadores perderán su medio
de vida que Los visitantes de nuestro
Parque Nacional que quieren experimentar
su vida salvaje desaparecerán en unos
años
ambos países están trabajando para
encontrar el origen de la contaminación
creando Una discordia entre ambas
naciones inicialmente los expertos
atribuyeron este desastre a los bajos
niveles de agua y a las altas
temperaturas debido a las recientes olas
de calor en Europa Pero los primeros
análisis realizados desde brandeburgo
detectaron substancias tóxicas que
podrían proceder de vertidos de mercurio
probablemente de una planta Industrial
polaca
espero tener ahí más información y por
supuesto espero una total AC y
transparencia de la parte polaca sobre
lo que ocurrió lo que llevó a este
desastre sin embargo el lado polaco
desestimó las investigaciones alemanas y
dijo el Instituto veterinario del Estado
ha completado las pruebas de metales
pesados en los peces descartó que los
metales pesados fueran la causa de la
muerte de los peces se están realizando
más análisis los primeros informes
fueron hechos por los polacos el 28 de
julio Pero no avisaron a los alemanes
hasta hace tres días probablemente
porque no se imaginaron que la corriente
iba a arrastrar a los peces río abajo
hasta Alemania
en noticias de América en Colombia la
vicepresidentada Francia Márquez se
posicionó hoy de manera simbólica en una
ceremonia con comunidades indígenas en
su tierra natal Márquez es la primera
mujer afro en llegar a la
vicepresidencia en este país
sudamericano como fórmula del presidente
Gustavo Petro Márquez estuvo en Suárez
su Municipio del departamento del cauca
al suroeste de Colombia en una región
lastrada por el conflicto armado y los
cultivos ilícitos la vicepresidenta Se
comprometió con la denominada paz total
bandera de la nueva administración
pasamos a Perú donde se reportó que hubo
vuelos cancelados hoteles saturados y
boletas agotadas este verano Los
viajeros se encuentran varios problemas
durante sus vacaciones después de dos
temporadas interrumpidas por la pandemia
de covid 19 el turismo repunta pero
varios sitios turísticos no logran
gestionar el flujo de visitantes en este
país cientos de turistas se manifestaron
frente a la entrada de Machu Picchu
después de que les fuera negado del
acceso
frente a la entrada de la ciudadela inca
de Machu Picchu cientos de turistas se
agolpan algunos de ellos intentan saltar
Las barreras de seguridad una suspensión
de la venta de entradas para Acceder al
sitio a enfadado a los comerciantes y a
los turistas
organizado
de horario para la visita
Lamentablemente se ve porque un centro
tan importante la maravilla del mundo
estemos pasando estos malos momentos por
la incapacidad de nuestras autoridades
Me parece que hace muy mal en el
Ministerio de cultura porque en realidad
no lo está tomando en serio esto y me
parece
una estafa que tienen que vender a los
extranjeros en 84 dólares 95 dólares
si bien las autoridades no han dado
ninguna explicación sobre la suspensión
las entradas a Machu Picchu están
sujetas a cuotas una medida tomada en
2019 para proteger este patrimonio
arqueológico construido en una montaña
en el siglo 15 al inicio entraron 3000
visitantes cada día la cuota ahora es de
5000 personas después de una primera
manifestación contra la suspensión de
las entradas hace dos semanas una cifra
que sigue siendo insuficiente para
gestionar el flujo de visitantes que
regresaron en masa tras la pandemia
el escritor Sherman rushdy permanece en
un hospital Del Noroeste del estado de
Pensilvania pero ya sin respiración
asistida tras el violento ataque con
cuchillo que sufrió este viernes en un
evento literario el agresor tiene 24
años y se declaró inocente hoy ante la
justicia ampliamos en el siguiente
informe de Samuel Salgado
Este es el momento exacto del ataque al
escritor británico de origen indio
cuando se preparaba para una conferencia
en el estado de Nueva York la policía
pudo someter al agresor de inmediato a
quien identificaron con el nombre de
Jade y matar quien este sábado Se
declaró Inocente de intento de asesinato
en segundo grado y otros cargos a los
que se le acusa la próxima cita con la
justicia será el 19 de agosto Mientras
tanto deberá permanecer en prisión
preventiva tras el ataque el escritor
salman rochy sigue luchando por su vida
en un hospital Del Noroeste del estado
de Pensilvania al que fue trasladado en
un helicóptero y remitido a cirugía
es un individuo que ha pasado décadas
diciendo la verdad al poder
Alguien que ha estado ahí afuera sin
miedo a pesar de las amenazas que lo han
perseguido durante toda su vida
recibió tres puñaladas en el cuello y
cuatro en el estómago Su agente
literario Andrew Willy dijo que uno de
los brazos del escritor está gravemente
afectado así como su hígado y su ojo
derecho luego de permanecer un día con
respiración asistida este sábado la
condición médica de Rush y presentó
avances y ya no necesitó más conexión a
un ventilador su obra literaria le causó
enemigos en el campo religioso en 1989
Irán ordenó la muerte de roshti al
acusarlo de blasfemia se cumplen 75 años
de la partición entre India y Pakistán
en este último país miles de personas se
congregaron en la ciudad de la Ford
acompañando al ex Primer Ministro inbran
para conmemorar la fecha el evento
terminó siendo una especie de acto
político en el que Khan hizo un llamado
a buscar la verdadera libertad fue en
agosto de 1947 cuando el mandato
británico que India de mayoría hindú y
Pakistán de mayoría musulmana
proclamaron su independencia desde
entonces ambas naciones han peleado Tres
Guerras en medios de millones de
familias que quedaron separadas por esta
partición
alija sambacain nació en 1946 tan solo
un año antes de la partición de India y
Pakistán tras su independencia de Reino
Unido su familia era una de las millones
de familias musulmanas que había en
India pero tras la creación de Pakistán
tuvo que irse con sus abuelos de Nueva
Delhi dejando atrás por décadas a parte
de sus familiares
mi madre estaba enferma en ese momento
fui a conocerla y a mi madre después de
mucho tiempo estaba postrada en la cama
las debía del hospital y luego estuve 15
o 16 días con ella muy bien pero cuando
me fui de India Nunca imaginé que no la
volvería a ver
la división de Pakistán e India sigue
presente para muchos cinco años después
debido a su gran dureza la independencia
de India se dio en un contexto de
enfrentamiento entre los diferentes
grupos religiosos y étnicos de esta
nación una tensión que degeneró en la
ruptura del territorio en tres partes la
actual India de mayoría hindú Pakistán
de mayoría musulmana y Pakistán Oriental
actualmente conocido como bangladesh
también de mayoría musulmana una
decisión que hizo que hasta 15 millones
de personas tuvieran que desplazarse de
sus hogares para llegar al país que
reconocía a su religión como mayoritaria
un desastre humanitario que ocasionó
entre 1 y 3 millones de muertos por
hambre y violencia y que separa en la
actualidad a muchas familias
hay miles de familias así algunas y
otras en más lugares
ella sienten un dolor intenso por la
partición y su corazón lo soporta como
nosotros
los gobiernos de ambas naciones deberían
escuchar las quejas de ciudadanos Avanti
un dolor difícil de sanar ya que la mala
relación actual entre India y Pakistán
que se han enfrentado en cuatro guerras
el siglo pasado ha contribuido a
profundizar la división
en Afganistán los tolimanes se
dispararon al aire para terminar con una
manifestación de mujeres en favor de su
derecho a la educación a Sólo dos días
del primer aniversario de la toma de
kabul por parte de este grupo
fundamentalista islámico las mujeres ven
como muchos de sus derechos más básicos
han sido eliminados
bajo amenazas y con disparos al aire así
es como los talibanes han terminado con
una manifestación de mujeres en kabul la
marcha fue frente al Ministerio de
Educación de Afganistán y ellas
protestaban ante los numerosos derechos
perdidos en este año de control talibán
un poder que les ha arrebatado entre
otras cosas su derecho a la educación
haciendo que algunas de estas mujeres y
niñas tengan que educarse en la
clandestinidad
y no me permitió venir aquí incluso
trató de detenerme cuando estaba en
octavo grado
cuando en realidad vengo a la escuela mi
hermano no sabe que vengo a la escuela y
solo mi madre me
apoyan tanto las estudiantes como sus
profesoras ponen su vida en peligro en
cada clase que asisten un riesgo que
están dispuestas a asumir a cambio de
tener una mínima oportunidad para
formarse detrás de esta educación
clandestina hay profe que ya sufrieron
la violencia talibán durante el anterior
gobierno entre 1996 y 2001 mujeres que
no quieren que estas niñas sufran lo que
ella sufrieron pues
estas niñas sean como yo deberían tener
un futuro mejor que yo
actualmente muchas de estas niñas
menores de edad se ven obligadas a
casarse como me tocó a mí me comprometí
a los 12 años he sufrido mucho para
obtener una educación es por eso que no
quiero que pasen por tanto
los talibanes terminaron con 20 años de
libertad para las mujeres el 15 de
agosto de 2021 luego de que tomaran
kabul tras una precipitada salida de
Estados Unidos y sus aliados
así terminamos esta emisión informativa
quédense en Francia 24
[Música]